un étudiant séminariste blanc
qui s'appelait Jonathan Daniels, de Cambridge, dans le Massachusetts.
Lui et moi,
nous faisions partie d'une génération de jeunes idéalistes
dont la vie avait été enflammée
par le feu de la liberté
que des personnes noires ordinaires propageaient dans toute la nation
et partout dans le Sud.
Nous étions allés dans le Comté de Lowndes
pour travailler pour le mouvement.
Et c'était un mouvement non-violent
pour racheter les âmes de l'Amérique.
Nous croyions que tout le monde,
noir ou blanc,
que les gens du Sud
trouveraient le chemin rédempteur
qui les sortiraient du carcan du racisme
qui les étranglait depuis plus de 400 ans.
Et lors d'un chaud jour d'été, en août,
Jonathan et moi sommes allés à une manifestation
de jeunes gens noirs locaux
contre l'exploitation
des métayers noirs
par les riches propriétaires terriens qui leur volaient leur argent.
Nous avions décidé de manifester avec eux.
Et le matin où nous sommes arrivés à la manifestation,
une foule d'hommes blancs nous attendait en hurlant
avec des battes de baseball, des fusils,
et toutes sortes d'armes imaginables.
Et ils menaçaient de nous tuer.
Et le shérif, voyant que nous étions en danger,
nous a arrêtés et mis dans un camion poubelle
et il nous a emmenés à la prison locale,
où il nous a mis en cellules
dans les conditions les plus inhumaines que vous pouvez imaginer.
Les gardiens menaçaient
de nous faire boire l'eau des toilettes.
On nous a enfin relâchés le sixième jour,
sans qu'on le sache, sans qu'on soit prévenus.
Du jour au lendemain,
on nous a fait partir.
Et nous savions que c'était un signe dangereux,
car Goodman, Schwerner et Chaney eux aussi avaient été forcés de quitter la prison
et avaient été assassinés car personne ne savait ce qui leur était arrivé.
Et donc, malgré notre résistance fervente,
le shérif nous a fait sortir de prison,
et bien sûr, personne ne nous attendait.
Il faisait chaud,
un de ces jours dans le Sud
où l'on peut sentir le bitume --
la vapeur suinter du bitume.
Et notre groupe d'environ 14 personnes
a choisi Jonathan Daniels,
Father Morrisroe, qui venait d'arriver dans le comté,
Joyce Bailey, une fille du coin de 17 ans,
et moi pour aller chercher à boire.
Quand nous sommes arrivés à la porte,
un homme blanc avec un fusil se tenait devant l'entrée,
et il a dit : « Je vais t'exploser le cerveau, salope ! »
et avant même que je puisse réagir,
avant même que je puisse comprendre ce qu'il se passait,
Jonathan m'a volontairement tirée par la chemise,
et je suis tombée en arrière, je pensais que j'étais morte.
Et à cet instant, quand j'ai levé la tête,
Jonathan Daniels se tenait dans la ligne de tir.
Il a été touché à ma place,
et il m'a sauvé la vie.
J'étais tellement traumatisée
et paralysée par cet événement,
durant lequel Tom Coleman délibérément,
intentionnellement,
a tué mon cher ami et collègue,
Jonathan Myrick Daniels.
Ce jour-là,
qui reste l'un des plus importants de ma vie,
j'ai vu l'amour et la haine
émaner de deux hommes blancs très différents
qui représentaient le meilleur et le pire de l'Amérique blanche.
Ma peine était si profonde
d'avoir vu Tom Coleman assassiner Jonathan sous mes yeux,
que je suis devenue muette,
et je n'ai pas parlé
pendant six mois.
J'ai enfin appris à toucher cette peine en moi
en vieillissant
et j'ai commencé à parler du mouvement de libération du Sud,
et j'ai commencé à relier mes histoires
avec les histoires de mes autres collègues et combattants de la liberté,
qui, comme moi, ont dû faire face au traumatisme meurtrier du racisme,
et qui ont perdu des amis en chemin,
et qui, eux aussi, ont été battus et jetés en prison.
50 ans ont passé.
Beaucoup de gens ont été battus et jetés en prison.
D'autres ont été assassinés comme Jonathan Daniels.
Et pourtant, nous sommes encore, en tant que nation,
englués
dans les sables mouvants du racisme.
Et partout où je vais dans le pays,
je vois et j'entends la souffrance.
Et partout je demande aux gens :
« Dites-moi, où avez-vous mal ? »
Voyez-vous et ressentez-vous la souffrance
que je vois et ressens ?
Je ressens et je vois la souffrance des gens noirs et métis
qui ressentent tous les jours la salve sadique du racisme
et qui sont tous les jours dépouillés de leurs droits civils et humains.
Et les gens qui le font utilisent des stéréotypes et des mythes
pour justifier leurs actes.
Partout où je vais,
je vois et j'entends des femmes
qui dénoncent --
qui dénoncent les hommes qui envahissent nos corps.
Ces mêmes hommes qui ensuite --
Ces mêmes hommes qui incitent au racisme
et qui volent notre travail et nous versent des salaires plus bas.
J'entends et je ressens la souffrance des hommes blancs
devant la trahison de ces mêmes puissants hommes blancs
qui leur disent que leur couleur de peau
est leur billet vers une vie décente et vers le pouvoir,
pour découvrir qu'en fait,
alors que le cercle de la blancheur rétrécit,
leurs billets ont expiré
et ne sont plus de première classe.
Maintenant que nous avons touché la souffrance,
nous devons nous demander :
« Où ai-je mal
et quelle est la source de ma souffrance? »
Je propose d'examiner
avec attention la culture de la blancheur.
C'est une rivière qui noie nos identités à tous
et nous noie dans une fausse uniformité pour protéger le statu quo.
Remarquez tous que j'ai dit culture de la blancheur
et pas les blancs.
Parce que selon mon estimation,
les blancs ne sont pas le problème.
C'est plutôt la culture de la blancheur.
Par culture de la blancheur,
je veux dire un ensemble systémique et organisé de croyances,
de valeurs, de savoirs canonisés, et même de religion,
qui maintiennent une hiérarchie du pouvoir
basée sur la couleur de peau, et contre les personnes de couleur.
C'est une culture
dans laquelle les blancs sont perçus comme des citoyens nécessaires et amicaux,
alors que les personnes de couleur, surtout les personnes noires,
sont perçues comme des étrangers
dangereux et menaçants,
qui représentent un danger clair et imminent
pour la sûreté et l'efficacité
de la culture de la blancheur.
Écoutez-moi et essayez d'imaginer
la culture de la blancheur comme un procédé déshumanisant
qui efface
nos identités multiples et imbriquées
telles que les origines ethniques, les classes, les genres et les sexualités,
pour...
pour maintenir le pouvoir par la cohésion.
Je crois, parce que je sais,
je crois que la culture de la blancheur
est une construction sociale.
Chacun de nous, de sa naissance à sa mort,
est socialisé dans cette culture.
Les personnes de couleur aussi.
Cela fait que les personnes de couleur, comme les blancs,
votent contre nos intérêts.
Vous allez me demander...
et mes étudiants me disent toujours que mes devoirs sont difficiles --
certains d'entre vous vont me demander, à juste titre :
« Comment y remédier ?
Ça a l'air si tout-puissant et si insurmontable. »
Je crois que nous devons y remédier,
car nous ne pouvons pas humaniser notre futur
si nous restons complices
de la culture de la blancheur.
Chacun de nous doit se reconnecter avec son soi authentique,
avec son soi ethnique authentique.
Et nous devons nous reconnecter avec les autres aspects de nos identités.
Et nous devons sortir des concepts
de blancs, métis et noirs
pour devenir qui nous sommes complètement.
Comment faire ?
Je crois que cela passe par nos récits collectifs.
Et nos récits collectifs doivent contenir nos histoires personnelles,
les arts,
les réflexions spirituelles,
la littérature,
et oui, même les percussions.
(Rires)
Ce doit être une narration collective,
car les histoires individuelles ne créent qu'un paradigme
où une histoire est comparée à une autre.
Ces différents modèles dont j'ai parlé ce soir
sont fondamentaux pour trouver le chemin
qui nous sortira du bourbier du racisme.
Et je veux parler d'un autre modèle très important.
Celui de la rédemption.
Je crois que les mouvements pour la justice raciale
doivent être rédempteurs plutôt que punitifs.
Et oui, je crois
que nous devons accorder la possibilité de rédemption à tout le monde.
Et l'on doit être prêts,
malgré les paroles cinglantes
qui pourraient venir de ces mêmes personnes qui nous oppressent,
je crois que nous devons les écouter
et essayer de comprendre où elles ont mal.
Nous devons le faire, je crois,
car notre rédemption est liée à leur rédemption.
Et nous ne serons pas libres
tant que nous ne nous serons pas tous rachetés de notre colère impardonnable.
Ce n'est pas un défi facile.
Et dans une société technologique, cela devient encore plus compliqué,
car nous utilisons souvent les technologies
pour perpétuer ces valeurs de racisme auxquelles nous cédons tous les jours.
Nous utilisons la technologie pour harceler,
pour perpétuer des propos haineux
et pour dégrader l'humanité des autres.
Et donc, je crois que si nous voulons humaniser le futur,
nous devons créer des manières d'utiliser la technologie
pas pour nous dégrader, mais pour nous élever
pour nous permettre de vivre au maximum de nos capacités.
Et je crois que la technologie
doit nous procurer des horizons plus larges
pour que nous puissions communiquer ensemble
et dépasser les espaces ségrégués dans lesquels nous vivons, chaque jour.
Je crois
que nous pouvons réussir si nous concentrons nos pensées
et nos espoirs sur ce but.
La question qui se pose à nous ce soir
est très sérieuse.
C'est : « Voulez vous être guéri ?
Voulez-vous être guéri ? »
Voulez-vous trouver la plénitude et vivre dans toutes vos identités ?
Ou voulez-vous continuer à cannibaliser vos identités multiples
pour privilégier une identité à l'autre ?
Voulez-vous rejoindre la longue liste
de générations de personnes
qui ont cru en la promesse de l'Amérique
et ont eu foi en la construction de la démocratie ?
Voulez-vous atteindre le maximum de votre potentiel ?
C'est ce que je veux, moi.
Et je crois que vous aussi.
Laissez-moi vous dire, très sérieusement,
que je crois en vous.
Et malgré tout,
je crois encore en l'Amérique.
J'espère ce cadeau que je vous ai fait ce soir,
que j'ai partagé avec vous ce soir,
vous ouvrira des chemins rédempteurs
pour que vous puissiez atteindre votre identité au complet
et devenir un participant majeur
dans l'humanisation du futur non seulement pour vous-même,
mais aussi pour notre démocratie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)